d-roc and i are going to connecticut
reiki rockin right either you understand
the intent of this company or you don't
like like I just want it this is binary
I don't care about these details nobody
in this [ __ ] company is going to
exist if they don't understand the [ __ ]
I'm doing
nobody zero like there's like like I'm
just I've zero tolerance for anybody
that doesn't understand do you
understand like let me save you guys
time will not make it at vaynermedia I
know that now
so so cool I just don't want to waste
time here on this conversation either
you [ __ ] understand that my intent is
always right that the were the best
[ __ ] intentional company of all time
and that we want to do everything that's
right for every single person or you do
not and any of your actions that think
that you forgot or that we've changed or
anything else puts you in a [ __ ]
vulnerable spot because I will not
tolerate it for a very long period of
time
I'm zero tolerance for the cliche thing
like we've changed it's inevitable oh
here it is cynicism is unacceptable
please let them please let them know we
hired 150 people we fired fifty people
and I'll fire everybody I don't need any
of them I just have no tolerance for
this I really don't this is annoying I'm
not in the slapping wrist business I'm
in the cutting their [ __ ] hearts out
of their bodies business there's no
kool-aid it's the water it's what we do
you know what I mean like kool-aid is
kool-aid comes from that dude [ __ ]
tricking people and killing them there's
no [ __ ] kool-aid it's our water it's
our [ __ ] water hey how are you
I'm so good I just want to take two
minutes and just congratulate you like
this is obviously such a big deal you're
such a beneficiary of the world that
we're trying to build which is it
doesn't matter how many years you've
been working or where you come from but
if you're great you get opportunities
and I think you're great and I'm just so
proud of you
it's really awesome I'm super pumped for
you and keep up the good work and keep
me close you know like I'm super willing
and capable of helping you all right
awesome you know welcome talk to you
later bye bye
cool right what happened nothing for me
there
I was South by two thousand eight or
nine I can remember which year Matt and
Mark gave one of the big keynotes
a lot of the focus has been on things
that we as a company aren't necessarily
as focused on and the thing that we are
trying to do at Facebook is just help
people connect and communicate more
efficiently and I give keynote first
part of it is that most people the wine
industry douchebags
so I'm just less of a douche bag that's
why people like
talking about where the world was gonna
go you know I was so it was so obvious
to me that the Sox was gonna build one
of the biggest companies in the world
there's something about this bigger
vision of where Facebook's going that
naturally lives with privacy is this
something that's going to keep cropping
up for you guys we need to give people
complete control over their information
right people need to be able to say
exactly who they want to share each
piece of information that they're
sharing so for example cell phone
numbers very hot um I think the most
recent started some twenty or twenty
five percent of people on Facebook have
their cell phone number shared and the
reason why they're able to do that is
because they can say I'd only want to
share this with my friends right if I
had to share it with sixty million
people then you wouldn't want to do that
so actually giving people very granular
control over who they share information
with actually allows those connection
and that communication to take place
just so cool just so cool to like you
know I think about like my great great
grandchildren if there was a picture in
the house of like my great-great
great-grandfather or whatever hanging
with like our great great charisma you
know with Thomas Edison or you know like
it's just cool like that's that's just
gonna be a fun narrative of like you
know being right about where the world's
going and to be very frank
whether it's meditation or virtual
reality or things that nature I an on
continuing
my ability to spot strategically where
consumers are going to be going where
people going to be going and spot the
people that are talented and changing
that and creating that world I think a
lot of times I talk about my hustle and
my work ethic and I almost
subconsciously undermine my strategic
ability I don't talk about my smarts I
almost don't even respect my smarts
myself which is probably why I don't
project it but um I definitely am far
more strategic about my business
decisions and where I'm going and I'm
going about doing it I think my actions
speak to my strategy a lot of people
like hey Gary why don't you put a more
strategy content and I laugh at you I
laugh at you because I say to myself if
you actually understood strategy you
would pay much more attention to what
I'm doing versus them what I'm saying
I've recognized one of my talents is to
use my words and my my storytelling
abilities to help so many of you get
started or continue to fight and I think
that my actions the way I put out my
content how do I do it when do I do it
why do I do it where do I do it what am
I making is it video as a pictures as it
quotes a my tagging what time my posting
why am i embedding youtube videos right
now versus native on dailyvee because
it's getting more organic reach why is
that happening
you know my actions speak to my strategy
and so for a lot of you that are looking
for more strategic content I would
implore you to start understanding that
strategy is better to be if you want to
learn strategy if you want to become
more strategic if you want to be smarter
about things I recommend that you don't
look for people like me to tell you how
to do it I recommend that you learn how
to watch people like me and how
I'm at Foxwoods giving a keynote to some
executives for Madison Square Garden
should be a lot of fun looking forward
to it I want to do more kaiju I'm gonna
start doing more characters grandma V
hopes you have the best day of the year
love you I just want to say that in
grandma bees day we hustled harder you
kids are [ __ ] soft in my day a
business was something that made money
not something that raised money that's
the mean is my red flag right here is
our interceder
banner everybody here has a really good
thought and opinion on Facebook
Instagram and snapchat advertising yet
98% of you have never placed an ad or
understood what's actually happening
underneath there so we live in a world
of headline reading ecosystem versus
lack of practitioner ship and there's an
enormous opportunity I sit in executive
meetings and in business meetings 24/7
365 and I watch smart people who know
what's actually happening in society how
cut really just shoot complete [ __ ]
because they know for inside their
organization this is what's acceptable
this is what's respected by the upper
brass and this is what's not going to
get you in trouble what happens is my
friends is this is what happens during
times of innovation and that's what's
happening right now
shit's gonna hit the fan the future
Fortune 500 companies that you're going
to be looking to work for a decade from
today are going to be looking at your
body of work and the people that were in
that room that go on to get other jobs
are going to be judging you for being
historically incorrect in your strategy
and so you have so much more upside to
actually say what you believe because
that's been the funny part right I go to
I was just a can the advertising
festival I send these panels I talk this
[ __ ] everybody else goes he's wrong
TV growth is better than ever
did a they all like you know they all
gang up on me cuz they're all in the
agency holding companies and like [ __ ]
this guy da-da-da-da-da right and then a
three
o'clock in the morning while we're all
drinking rose' at the Carlton they come
up to me they're like you're [ __ ]
right right there's not a single person
that's capable of being in this room
that doesn't know I'm right that we're
spending tons of [ __ ] money on dumb
[ __ ] it's just that everybody's in the
same ecosystem thank you for having me
Neil your vessel flaring yes do you rock
get this yes
nice job that's great thanks man yeah
yeah it seemed like they got a some
value out of it
grandma V just wants to remind you that
in my day
everybody said radio was king and I said
this TV thing's gonna be big
really well brother how are you good
yeah so tell me what's on you tell me
what's on your mind she needs to she
needs to she needs to realize like I she
doesn't know what she's talking about
she uh you need to be her like we need
to be her friend sooner than later
because because she because because I'm
the toughest of the I'm the easiest and
then the hardest when I get to that
place like I'm the I'm the easiest until
I decide and then there's no going back
yeah I mean but you know you know I mean
like that that's silly because if you're
right if you're wrong even once then it
doesn't that it eliminates everything
that's what people understand you're
under estimating optimism if you're if
you're right seven out of ten times but
you didn't allow somebody that came in
that was going to be a superstar because
you went that route it's a lot easier to
go that route you know what I mean
or reverse I mean like if you start
really auditing I promise you some of
the people you were excited about have
not materialized the way we wanted to
what's what's not a crapshoot is
creating an environment that allows
people that could go one way or the
other to thrive
another crapshoot is eliminating people
that don't [ __ ] get it
but if there's a difference between thin
ice and the beginning of a process that
gets to thin ice like kind of you know I
mean the beginning of a process where
the seesaw is now going in the other
direction the seesaw went from you're
sitting on the ground and and and you
know you're that means you're winning
because you weigh more than thing on the
other side now the seesaw is even and
since you were starting by sitting on
the ground and the seesaw is now even
that's not a good place
that means it's heading in the wrong
direction you want you you you want the
seesaw to flip over your head you know
what I mean hey brother good I'm super
not pumped about this whole situation
like I'm not happy and whatever I don't
I have to unwind it and I'm not pointing
fingers but I'm not happy thanks brother
bye there's no competition here I've
been selling [ __ ] while Gary was still
in diapers it's all granny
hello ladies hello
hey I'm good guys how are you tell me
before we get started I'd love to get a
quick 3 to 4 minute update I would say
I'm not against it I just want you guys
to know I'm very sensitive to it
right I'm an old dog in business and
I've seen it happen so many times and I
don't want to get into a place where by
circumstance we can't have the kind of
relationship I want to continue to have
I want to I want to be very upfront to
tell you what makes me nervous but I
definitely don't want to restrict
anything and I do feel like as long as
I'm communicating you'll communicate
with me and we can figure anything out
in the future you know what I mean
Francesca asks between starting a
podcast and starting a web series other
than talent what are the factors to
consider a lot I mean talent is the
variable if you're not talented enough
there's no tactics there's no growth
hacking there's no strategy that's going
to help you you have to be worth
listening to worth watching the other
things to consider a distribution so
there's the quality of the content and
then there's distribution what uh you
know I actually think that a lot of
people think I'm talented or I have it I
actually think my distribution
strategies have been better than my
actual talent you know doing YouTube
early on then Twitter you know you you
know the way we do Facebook video now
even this piece of content I think my
distribution strategies have been strong
and and have been a variable in my
success in the way that I think there's
a lot of people that could be a model or
somebody that's funny on a show it's
just who gets picked and who gets the
awareness so I think you're in control
your distribution more than you are in
your talent so I think the biggest thing
Francesca do all of you have to really
pay attention to is where are you
distributing your content is your
content relevant to that platform how do
you hack that platform to be somebody
that gets awareness those are things
that I most focus on the climate for
fundraising has gotten very difficult
which is why you're seeing a lot of
things start to fold and then this is a
very narrow niche thing so I I think
this I think one of the ways to think
about this is I was thinking a lot about
what to talk about in this call one of
the things that's running through my
mind is what would the world look like
if you did a whole lot of fifty hundred
thousand and two hundred thousand dollar
checks one of the things you should
contemplate is how much do you need to
raise that gives you enough runway to
kind of like build a meaningful business
in your mind and how do you piece it
together with individuals maybe instead
of an institution good to hear your
voice man looking forward to seeing you
I appreciate I'm looking forward to
visiting you there on your home turf and
I'm glad we got to do this call and I
love you and I hope you have a great 4th
and I'll see you soon
please feel free to be overzealous with
our relationship if that can help you
get a gig I'm thrilled to get on the
phone with anybody any recruiting firm
any CEO of an agency and vouch for you
and I think you can throw around my name
a little bit more aggressively than you
think you might have been able to thanks
brother no worries man I wish you well
take care bye-bye
how you treat former employees is just
as important as how you treat your
current employees exactly it's a purpose
right there
congratulations I've seen the pictures
and everything and it's so amazing how
you doing that feels crazy right and
scary oh my god that's like the first
the first two months I would literally
go into misha's room and check if she
was breathing I was scared crapless if
you have a good balance of understanding
you as an executive and a decision maker
and a leader and you understand how to
read your competitors and how to read
your consumers using those data points
what are they doing how are they acting
what are they spending money on what are
they creating if you're a fast follower
to those data points you can often time
have success and more importantly
everybody who's reading this article has
different businesses in different
markets with different competitors with
different moments of time with different
upsides that's the beauty of you it's
like being a great fisherman like you
can't explain it you just have the feel
for the rod
I'm not a fisherman I'm just looking at
a big body of water which led me to
create that analogy all right granny
beam you think more people are gonna
screen shoot your snap over mine
I sure do you let a young whippersnapper
I'm gonna prove it right now the next
two snaps pick either me or Gary's snap
like that granny bee versus Gary
yes
oh she's huge no no it's early
oh I'm winning
I know are you right there's a 130 I got
90 more views than heart literally
competing with her as if she's real
already freaking out boss not even close
no she's up 51 31
had to see the boys seeing up my two
brother-in-law's my best friend my
cousin one of my good friends Jeff was
manager at Wine Library it should be a
fun day a little baseball game action
get into the holiday weekend so good
stuff good day fun to give a talk a
bunch of calls a lot of intensity you
know a lot of running the business
through the phone a lot of operational
stuff HR stuff client stuff so good
productive day
you know also navigated a lot of
business through my phone while you
weren't watching and the the emergence
of a true superstar of one set of
generation superstar grandma B so all in
all quality quality effort wishing all
of you a great 4th of July weekend
I know this would probably are after
that so I hope you had a good one
Oh
nice pants beat up nice nice new pants
how many no no I really like really
compare
this